(ethereal music)
- When you're looking up at
a beautiful dark night sky,
what goes through my
mind is the wonder of it.
It's just so incredibly vast.
I never lose interest in it,
because it's just so beautiful.
I wanted others to enjoy the night sky
as much as they could.
The best way to do that is to
build your own planetarium.
(piano music)
The Kovac planetarium is located
in the north woods of Wisconsin,
in the little town of Monico.
I began the project in 1997,
and it was finally opened
to the public in 2007.
I started from scratch,
a lot of trial and error.
I had no blueprints.
There were many, many times
where I had so many roadblocks come my way
that I wanted to give up.
I just had to convince
myself and my neighbors
that I wasn't crazy.
And of course, when I started
putting up this planetarium,
that was when people really
started to wonder about me.
So it's kind of neat.
I built this thing,
and now I get to maintain it,
keep it running for the shows.
(twinkling music)
This is the largest
mechanically-operated planetarium
in the world.
All the stars are
hand-painted one dot at a time
with glow in the dark, luminous paint.
It took about five months.
This is the only planetarium
in the whole world
that has the night sky as
glow in the dark paint.
This is beyond normal,
but some of us actually
put our dream into reality
and do it.
I took ordinary materials,
and I made something
extraordinary out of them.